I bow down outfit number two my goodness
Shania
congratulations holding that equal play
award out there oh Kelsey's Calling You
Queen
how much do we love Kelsey love deeply
and how about that red carpet debut with
Kelsey and Chase Stokes
Chase I mean come on aren't is aren't
they dreaming together very dreamy yes I
would say yes that I would say history
me no good looks there no good looks
congratulations on your award holding it
up there on stage in front of the
audience I mean what was going through
your mind I mean these are the kind of
moments where I really feel empowered to
uh raise others up and it just gives me
more of a platform to Champion
uh the cause it's actually a cause it's
become a Cause right it really has so
yeah it was it's great to be a part of
it and how about Meg the stallion
presenting you
[Music]
I love her she is so what a sweetheart
and we were sitting together in the
audience uh yeah we really gelled very
well I really love her as a person I
mean she's a great talent
um
I was just glad she didn't ask me to
twerk out there you know I'm like I
would have had to say no I can't that I
cannot do but
um no she was amazing and so said so
many sweet things and yeah I was really
flattered that she was there for me I
think you would gel well musically too I
think so too I was thinking that yeah I
was okay so we're on the same wave
because I just think yeah I think that
that would be that would really work uh
from your lips actually I was gonna say
from your lips to God's ears but you
make it happen
you can make it
make it yeah no I love her whole mind
yeah speaking of collabs I talked to
Alanis Morissette on the red carpet and
of course you two are both Canadian
Queens what do we have to do to get you
two together oh I mean you know we've
crossed past so many times over the
years and
we just never did work together we
should of course as fellow Canadians
look at us making things hopefully
happen back here putting everything out
there we're putting it out in the
universe
[Music]
thank you